this morning in our Saturday sessions
soul and gospel legend Mavis Staples the
multiple Grammy winner is a member of
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and a
Kennedy Center honoree Mavis O perform
from her new album we get by in a moment
but first a celebration of Mavis 80th
birthday she won't blow out the candles
officially til next month but the
party's already started the Newport Folk
Festival organized all-star birthday
tributes in Nashville Los Angeles and at
the Apollo Theater here in New York
which is where we caught up with Mavis
[Music]
Mavis Staples first appeared on the
Apollo stage in 1956 with her family's
band the Staple Singers more than six
decades later Mavis is as vibrant as
ever you feel almost more successful now
than you ever were in some ways I mean
that's kind of amazing really amazing at
80 yeah at 80 I'm supposed to be going
on in you know but I'm coming all out
the birthday party at the Apollo had an
all-star guest list David Byrne
performed a Talking Heads classic with
me
Jon batiste joinder for a Staple Singers
classic
[Music]
the concert also drew Jason is boy I
just think maybe this is one of the
greatest singers and interpreters and
songwriters and performers ever Norah
Jones is an amazing artist but this is
just a warm sweet human as well and
rising star Maggie Rogers have such a
reverence for her that couldn't not come
so any chance to celebrate Mavis you
know know she was alive first in this
building I wouldn't be like that at 80 I
I want to be like that mouth the Apollo
was just the beginning of the
celebration you don't have been one
party you're having three parties check
that out one one hadn't been enough I
mean I've been around a long time yeah
so it really should be five because I
mean I've gone from eight to 80 I
started singing when I was eight years
old yeah and I'm still rolling
Mavis started singing with her siblings
in the Staple Singers led by her dad pop
staples the gospel group would march
with dr. Martin Luther King jr. and help
provide the soundtrack to the civil
rights movement before scoring a string
of chart hits in the 1970s Mavis is
latest solo album we get by pays homage
to those early years with a cover photo
taken by Gordon Parks in Alabama in 1956
I saw those little girls and in there
they they they just want to ride on the
slide they just want anything swing yeah
what he just went in but those little
girls reminded me of my sisters and I
you know we used to do the same thing we
couldn't go to the beach we couldn't
play in the park on the grass I just
felt it I felt that picture
[Music]
what have you done to keep your voice in
such great shape dinner - a little honey
yeah and then I do my exercise yes no
it's not the only exercise she does you
box hey you don't know nothing about me
Anthony a box I got pink boxing blue I
have a t-shirt you do have a t-shirt
with my dukes up like that did they sell
those at the merch table okay I'm in I
used to box years ago when I was a kid
yeah I didn't know it was boxing but I
was fighting all the time because the
kids were especially in Mississippi they
would pick on me they just you sound
like a boy because my voice was so heavy
you know and I so I sound like a boy huh
okay oh yeah I'm eight years old but I'm
fine yeah on fire Anthony
[Music]
where do you find the energy to keep
doing this Mavis I love what I'm doing
and I just try to stay healthy I'm not
eating a whole lot of pork chops anymore
it's you're nuts
no no no I have Salman disappointed I'm
not thinking about no return I'm having
too much fun you live to sing I live to
say that's I live to sing Thank You
Anthony
I really do that's a good title I live
to sing for my friends and family for my
Anthony I live to sing oh I'm keeping
that one Mavis keep that one okay keep
it ever because you get a percentage you
know I was gonna say do I get a song oh
yeah